prada c'est pas mal aussi bien pu voter
un texte
je crois qu'un malaise laquelle ces bons
chiffres à theix savez j'adore le tennis
est en ce moment c'est roland garros
donc on va en parler quand même oui avec
laurent ruquier
alors il faut le savoir car le stade de
roland garros tire son nom d'un aviateur
français qui s'est crashé et depuis la
tradition respectée puisque chaque année
des tennisman français à vienne se
crasher à roland garros c'est pas fini
de ton texte
j'ai quand même beaucoup d'admiration
pour jo-wilfried tsonga
parce que je le trouve très constant oui
que ce soit sur un court où dans une pub
kinder bueno
il joue toujours aussi mal ya aussi
nicolas bedos eu envie de nous parler
tennis nicolas bonneau ce qu'a fait un
triomphe dans les molières en sept
semaines
salut à demain c'est moi bedos son
meilleur ennemi sache mon cher petit
pakistanais au physique anémiée etc
autant le tennis tu t'excites autant il
me laisse froid et puis des français qui
se font ridiculiser par toutes les
autres nations excuse moi mais j'ai
l'impression de regarder l'eurovision
mais aussi mon sri lankais préférées
comment vouloir gagner quand on sait
qu'en cas de victoire c'est l'engrenage
d'abord tu chantes saga africa puis tu
finis par susurrer des chansons inepte
avec une voix de fausset le tout
sponsorisé par sloggi hanouna monture
mais nador et pense à nos 1 2 grâce
pense à noah en voyant ce qu'il advient
des vainqueurs à roland garros comment
veux tu que nous français n'ait pas
envie de nous et on à stéphane marie
vous connaissez s'était pas de mari de
silence ça pousse un ce jardinier qui
était venu nous voir qui est extrêmement
populaire
il voulait également nous donner son
avis sur roland-garros - jamais pivoines
c'est stéphane à moi roland garros
désole cyril mais j'aime pas du tout moi
saisi là qu'est ce qu'ils font est
jardinier
on dira un terrain vague voilà qui
pousse fois roséen faut que ça vers 10 1
je ferai des versets 200 tonnes de fumée
de lapin se seraient vite réglés en vous
mais ces deux mois je vous fais
wimbledon alors c'est bizarre que noah
est pas gagné wimbledon
lui qui aime tellement ça a l'air bon
on a aussi la chance de recevoir ce soir
le grand couturier karl lagerfeld a
écouté mon cher cyril je vais regarder
roland garros et j'ai été révulsé par
les tenues arborées par ces jeunes gens
à l'image de rafael nadal
ouais une sorte de petit taureau sous
stéroïdes
engoncé d'un tee shirt sans manche digne
d'une compétition de tuning dans le nord
pas de calais ah oui et ce n'est pas sur
france 2 qu'il faut le diffuser mais
dans confessions intimes et djokovic
mais de grâce l'été approche alors
pourquoi un banquier en permanence ce
bonnet en poils de ragondins sur la tf
pardon ce sont ses cheveux
alors il devrait intenter un procès en
diffamation à son coiffeur 1 et enfin
gaël monfils mon dieu là c'est trop trop
de masse trop de muscles trop de cheveux
fous il va rien d il va arriver c'est là
rires
il arrivait à un ballot c'est serena
williams oui bah oui papa étonnant
qu'elle ait donné son nom à une marque
de rasoirs 1 c'est antoine de caunes qui
est avec lui bonsoir bonsoir je vous
sais passionné de tennis aussi s décidé
de vous résumer à bagnères la semaine
des français à roland garros c'est bien
simple
comme chaque année ça a été de la
déconfiture non non ils ont
ils ont elles plongé se rouler dans la
terre battue ah oui et que ça n'a pas
été de la tarte sport et ses frères oui
je pense pas au nom
za fondamentale chaque fois avec un bel
esprit sportif
ils ont serré la main de leurs
adversaires aux tartes et gâteaux et les
ont embrassé
maroc
ce matin